all right here now with much more
ranking member of the House Judiciary
Committee Ohio Congressman Jim Jordan
your investigation is into
um the whether or not our FBI has been
politicized and whether or not the
Department of Justice has been
weaponized now we have the Twitter files
where Elon Musk clearly said A week ago
Saturday that election interference in
fact took place by the suppression of
information on Twitter I agree with him
he talked about how the media is
complicit and how Twitter became
basically an a propaganda arm of the
democratic party when you put that
together with what we know about the
bidens and the laptop you know look at
the Barista deal here you have a vice
president withholding a billion dollars
until a prosecutor gets fired you have
six hours son of a bee they do it and it
turns out the prosecutors and
investigating his son with no experience
being paid Millions what do you call
that right
well yeah I pressure or you were just
talking about intimidation I mean never
forget Sean early January 2017 Jim Comey
went up to New York to pressure
president Trump and tell him about the
dossier the dossier that he already knew
was baloney that he knew was false but
it was all designed to intimidate
president Trump now we get this
intimidation that Mr Turley and you were
talking about coupled with what the
Democrats have done to the Supreme Court
over the last year trying to intimidate
the court introducing legislation to
pack the court intimidation is how the
left operates and it was intimidation
and the whole pressing back and
suppressing this key information just
days before the most important election
we have the presidential election in the
fall of 2020. so yeah we've got to look
into this and how political that justice
department has become but it gets even
deeper because the FBI had Hunter's
laptops since the December of 2019. okay
then we head into the election in 2020
they knew that the likelihood that this
that this in fact would be made public
was real and you have members of the FBI
meeting weekly with every big tech
company warning them that this type of
story about Hunter according to Joel
Roth might actually come out and you
don't want to be disseminating false
information that sounds to me like the
FBI that should have known pretty darn
well by that point 11 months later that
that laptop was real they're telling big
Tech to be on the lookout because it's
probably false it turns out they did
intimidate every big tech company what
does that mean in terms of putting the
thumbs on the scales of a presidential
election
well yeah that's exactly what they did
but by them telling big Tech to be on
the lookout for a Russian information
operation that was all it seems to me
that was all part of their information
operation here's what I want to know
those 51 guys who signed that letter was
Jim Baker talking to them he had to know
many of those guys when he served as
Chief counsel at the FBI he had to work
with those guys when they were spying on
President Trump's campaign and when he
was taking information from Hillary's
lawyer Mr zusman then when he goes to
Twitter is he working with those guys
did he participate in helping them draft
that letter or did he encourage them to
draft that letter because you got you
got Jim Baker who was involved in trying
to stop Trump from winning in 2016 and
there here he is at Twitter preventing
president Trump from winning in 2020.
maybe maybe it was Jim Baker who was the
actual insurance policy remember we we
saw those text messages from struck and
Paige maybe the real insurance policy
was later Jim Baker in 2020 helping
Twitter keep that information from the
American people I don't know but we need
to get to the bottom of all this so that
it never ever happens again do you
believe the Washington Post and Jonathan
turley's interpretation of this that
they are telegraphing an intimidation
campaign against Witnesses against
investigators like yourself uh against
the media if they dare report any of
these things do you think this is an
organized well-orchestrated intimidation
effort to protect the bidens
of course it is and this is not the
first story there was one four weeks ago
right after the election Politico puts a
story out David Brock and this group are
coming after anyone who investigates the
bidens so it's not not that they just
told us once with the Washington they've
now told us twice so when they when
someone tells you once okay but they've
told us now twice of course they're
coming after folks but the fact is we
have a duty to do the work to get the
truth out there to get the facts out
there that's step one in stopping this
kind of baloney from happening in the
future we can't have a justice
department that's political we can't
have a justice department that's working
hand in hand with the biggest social
media platforms to limit what
information Americans see you just can't
focus on and do our job they have had
since December 1900 Biden's laptop and
they've done nothing with it what does
that tell you about the FBI and the doj
and the investigation you begin in
January
tells me that these 14 whistleblowers
FBI agents who've come talk to us and
taken whistleblower status it tells me
they're probably right that you should
believe them that their credible good
men and women who've come talk to us
than telling us how how crazy things are
there and that's why we're going to
investigate and get the facts all right
Jim Jordan well uh clearly you're not
going to be intimidated all those years
wrestling have paid off no doubt about
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else